alors on attend un petit tour de table
qui est tellement proche de ses voisins
qu'il les entend même faire l'amour mais
chez moi ces fenêtres sur courts ce que
j'ai vu sur un hôtel je sais je suis
déjà venu chez vous mais oui je n'eus le
réveiller un jour à 4 heures du matin il
a jamais répondu l'élu peur est là bas
où la bombe lacrymo derrière le ou pas
ouais c'est vrai ouais j'ai même fait
démonter par une échelle et où il avait
laissé la fenêtre ouverte
ouais il c'était la canicule un nom
c'est moi il ya un hôtel et donc je vois
des gens mais là on est en direct
[Applaudissements]
oui pour la tuerie
ils sont venus sur le mois ce que nous
avons écrit alors ça ça nous arrivera
jamais quatre jours ça va partir en
cacahuète total vous libre alors louis
xiv
[Rires]
c'est chez moi j'ai un hôtel et je vois
des gens rend parfois on regarde et le
replay tpm b c'est vrai ou parfois faire
un ou des genres muel gigot mais un
gigot ou chatouiller le déni fars mais
oui je voulais raconter que moi j'avais
entendu mes voisins mais en fait je
pensais qu'il se battait pas ce que
j'entendais des cris des morsures de
bois j'entendais des frais c'est moi ou
vous habite à côté de la maison de
charles ingalls
j'aimerais bien aussi entendu des cris
tellement fort que du coup j'ai appelé
la police
la police est intervenue et ma voisine
est arrivé les cheveux comme ça tout en
transpiration elle m'a dit écoutez moi
si vous faites pas du bruit quand vous
faites l'amour c'est pas bon c'est pas
mon problème
moi en tout cas je m'éclate au pieu
alors amusez vous aussi alors oui elle
m'a dit moi je viens pas appelé la
police quand vous chantez vous avez tout
la star accompli la police et voilà qu'à
stéphane bak a eu un truc toi que tes
bras nantes a dit entendu des voix non
mais stéphane à vendre à bas les fans a
vendu admea parte parce qu en fait
j'étais au premier et tous mes voisins
metella cendres de leurs clopes choper
gueule non c'est tombé sur mes enfants
ce serait une bataille quelqu'un ratu
naisa maintenant oui c'est pour ça et
maintenant j'ai un enfant qui joue du
piano juste à côté de ma chambre à 6h30
nom et ses parents je renvoyais
sérieusement je renvoyais la plus belle
lettre de janvier et j'ai envoyé mes dvd
ils m'ont renvoyé mais non merci
il est brun continue je lai et je
comprends moi moi qui joue du piano
quand les gens se plaignent que je
voulais pouvoir
ça m'énerve ce soir de jouer
non mais je vous dis je fais la 9e et là
je la joue pendant des heures il ya des
gens qui se plaignent samedi dans votre
hôtel particulier on ne vous entend ce
de dota
alors qu'elle anime c'est là votre
insolence habite dans un immeuble s'est
tassé de jean quelqu'un auger quelqu'un
en bas j'ai quelqu'un à côté et les gens
s'ils ne se plaignent pas là son
jardinier sa gouvernance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
demandez c'est bien une force jusqu'à
soirée parce que ça sent la fin de
carrière vous avez entendu vos voisins à
ma voisine c'est ma mère alors alors
qu'hier déjà était le voisin d'une star
franchement pour moi quand j'étais
mannequin j'y vais à new york dans la
trump tower et la tour de trump tower
c'était comme s'il y avait une macro
n'daw légaré jugé dans un petit appart
qu'un copain m'avait prêté ouais j'étais
copine avec qui vend qu'à qui était
mannequin aussi dans la même agence
esahara il vend bien 24' en fait elle
m'avait fait visiter son appartement qui
était un peintre ou sur deux étages en
eaux de l'atlantique house et j'avais
croisé deux voiliers donald trump backup
ou coulton ces données que l'on freine
quand vous avez vu donald kohn
ouais et alors ils étaient dix points
brillants barrière il s'est intéressé
parce que j'étais un peu trop âgés ah
ouais j'avais 22 ans en fait
en fait je me dis papa c'est une
émission problème problème je le savais
on le savait alors oui avoue chaussée
elle l est et je savais qu'il était non
elle était voisine cela dix premiers
dans mon immeuble je sais pas si ça
gronde
oui c'est un moyen sûr je suis d'arabes
c'est qu'on est très loin de ça 3
j'avais j'avais rapidement célarié et
tonton david et on adore j'avais michel
sardou je me rappelle toujours que c'est
vrai et vous l'attendiez chanter répéter
tout ça mais pourquoi pas ce que vous
croyez vraiment alors mais regardez
normal
vous regardez c'est à dire qu'il croit
que des colloques et des chanteurs
salaires en série
[Rires]
j'étais dans des blocs de michel sardou
alors ok de goma bonjour michel de mapa
départs et arrivées des départs et c'est
des poussines ont ou non bah moi
j'habitais à côté d'un propre blog ça
fait pas beaucoup de bruit à son temps à
chanter ni appétit mais c'est bon c'est
déjà bits à coder big star vous n'ont
jamais dit que la berd et la mer était
d'huile à cette agitation déjà le plaza
aujourd'hui oui attention plaza de mayo
qui a déjà eu une aventure avec son
voisin sa voisine au genre y avait un
petit buy longtemps s'est vu par la
fenêtre et à l'avancé reprenant le même
cours de théâtre sans se connaître et on
se regarde on n'y mettais ma voisine
non on a cru que c'était le destin qui
na waie réunis et on a un truc c'était
magique
non en fait c'était une histoire de
merde où il ya quand même des choses à
vous dire moi quand j'étais dans le
massachusetts
alors oui détenus et mannequin j'ai vécu
on a tous été mannequin s'était mal car
on le dit pas mais moi sur le terrain
il ya là un petit j'avais un petit
appartement à en beauté son dos à tokyo
où ça tuerait la selle c'est un truc de
fou quand même une cinq cas rien à ce
qui est en train de saper la daf sans
rigoler l'état de new york de deux
minutes à la tokyo dans cinq minutes
elle baille trou j'avais fait comme un
pays à bas tous quoi définit comme un
soap la laponie je suis jamais allé à
bâle mais on est allé on veut régler la
une qui trouver l'amour là bas haha ça
fait rêver en tout cas bravo vous
verriez vous allez voir le mec le sort
que vraiment il tape art à tokyo ouais
et tout d'un coup je me réveille en
plein milieu de la nuit à 3 heures du
matin et je me sens pas bien je tombe
non oui la tombe de fer s'en va en
guerre c'est un tremblement l'avait un
tremblement cassé la main ya toujours
des tremblements de terre en plein air
la nuit et deux on se sent un peu et
brieuc et brillant et bien voilà on est
brillante du coup on attendait on se
sent et brio
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
samedi le savez que je crois que ça
l'est dès que mes potes sa bataille face
à la fatigue mal comme ça cette émission
et brio mascella ah oui c'est ébriété
mais conduit autant conduire en état
d'ivresse
voilà là il reste les bouillons et brio
pour laisser sakho n'est fait je connais
ses doigts connaissez brio tient sur
trois que c'est un fromage à laisser
briller des secousses sismiques vous
tombez vous avez vraiment l'impression
d'être sous bien sûr dont moi j'ai peur
ouais donc je suis sorti de chez moi je
suis allé voir mon voisin a donc du coup
on a fait des secousses sismiques
ensemble quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais ça va vous allez 0 côté bourrin
vous arriverez à l'émission après merci
ou là alors moi j'avais repéré une fille
dans le rer
mais j'avais alors généralement
généralement la laisser couper là dans
une minute c'est la police qui a alors
et donc c'était tard le soir parce que
j'étais à la fac à jussieu donc on
rentrait tard j'avais repéré tous les
jours vers 23h entrée avec moi comme je
suis malin le wagon d'à côté est gelée
suivi voilà j'aime bien suivre les gens
comme s'en vont les habits mais c'est
vrai vous imaginez la pauvre personne
mais l'ami qu'il entend comme ça qui
voit une personne de ce nom mais le plus
jeune j'allais on était alors on peut
sortir de la photo de lui bébé mais n'a
pas dit où nous suivre voilà bah tu me
suis un peu la vente
[Applaudissements]
on va là que l'on l'a toujours en stock
noté mme vernet ce bébé si vous n'avez
jamais vu alors là on va plaisir ça sera
un bon cadeau de noël à monaco si
c'était chaud alors s'il était à la fac
parce qu'il avait déjà ce nom mais c'est
rien ça c'est rien on veut ou la casse
geneviève des bois
oui donc je la suis à un moment et je
vois qu'elle rentre dans l'immeuble à
côté de chez moi
aulas on était voisins et provoque ligne
et parce que l'histoire me passionne
mais oui mais peut-être vous mais nous
non et donc voilà je les suivis oui je
les guettait pendant des semaines et un
jour je crois qu'elles sortent des
valises et tout ça m'est à bbb dans ton
frigo s'avère lourd donc je vais l'aider
bref il est excusé moi vous êtes mon
obsession que tu des mois et là je vois
que vous avez dévalisé sous sol eh ben
je l'ait aidée à déménager et on a eu
trois mois d'aventuré vraie histoire
problème est tous les mecs de chez
demeco des déménagements et oui oui oui
va geler des avanies oui ça s'appelle
comme ça de fil en aiguille isabelle est
donc et vous vous êtes réveillés au bout
de trois mois trois mois
c'est une histoire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je fais
négrondes franchement il a été très très
bon
pas très très bien merci personne n'a
dit grand ballon peut pas faire mieux
certains ont voulu jamais non jamais non
dans le quartier non non non un petit
chapiteau pied du csa donc avant ça mais
ce que parent vous habitez juste à côté
lui s'est jamais vraiment un champ à 3 3
secondes et vous tient mais maintenant
avec sa belle-mère d'accord alors juste
un travail où il a reçu aussi des
missions vous déranger
[Rires]